we all know the name rosa parks whose
defiance on a montgomery alabama bus
became a turning point in the civil
rights movement back in 1955 but chances
are you may not have heard about this
woman her name is claudette colvin most
people don't know her story as a
teenager she was arrested nine months
before parks for the very same reason
refusing to give up her busy to a white
person her story is a very important
part of our civil rights history and now
there's a new development that you'll
see only on cbs mornings and we love
when this happens lead national
correspondent that's you david beck now
has an interview that we will and it's
got a twist as only you can do i've been
waiting for this all morning i can't
wait for you to see this and all of you
you don't hear about claudette colvin in
the history books but she should she's
now a great grandmother and for the past
66 years she has lived with a criminal
record
in what may be her final protest she
asked a judge in alabama to clear her
name by expunging her record
and the judge did it this is her story
and as gail said you do not want to miss
the surprise at the end
needing assistance now it's very nice to
meet you claudette colvin has spent most
of her 82 years as a convicted juvenile
delinquent who would go on to college
work as a nurse's aide and raise two
sons do you think of yourself as an
important figure in history no i think
of myself
as a survivor of the civil rights
struggle her place in the civil rights
struggle began when she was 15 years old
at the back of a crowded montgomery
alabama bus after school with three
friends i was sitting in the
session that was allowed for
a couple of people
and this white lady came the bus driver
demanded for the four seats and this is
you and three others students yes so
three of them got up yes and you refused
so i refused
because this wasn't an elderly white
lady this was a young white lady you're
sitting there
your classmates get up and move
yes what was going through your head as
to why you refused to stand
i said
i could not move because history had me
glued to the feet
and they said how is that i said well it
felt as though
harriet tubman hands were pushing me
down on one shoulder and sojourner's
truth hand
was pushing me down on the other
shoulder
now that happened nine months before
rosa parks was arrested for refusing to
give up her seat on a montgomery bus
overshadowing for decades what a
teenager had also done and the traffic
patroller came to the rear of the bus
and asked me
why i wasn't sitting there i told him i
was sitting there because
i paid my fare and it's my
constitutional rights
now watching this interview from a
nearby room was judge calvin williams
today he is the presiding judge of the
montgomery family court and then what
happened oh lo and behold two
squad car patrolman stopped and you know
cut the bus off and
came they stopped and we said oh man
we invited the judge to listen in
and hear colvin's account of what the
police did to her in 1955.
and he asked me why was i'm sitting
there
and i was even more defiant and i said i
paid my affair and it's my
constitutional rights he said
constitutional rights and i don't know
and they put me in the squad car
and their hand caught me through the
window claudette colvin was jailed
charged with disturbing the peace
breaking segregation law and found
guilty of assaulting police officers
clawing them with her fingernails they
said i clawed
the policemen and i kicked the police i
didn't do all of that was it the one and
only time in your life that you've gone
to jail yes
at the time i represented claudette
carvin there was no rosa parks case
as a young attorney fred gray later
portrayed by cuba gooding jr in the film
selma took up her case that's before he
went on to defend rosa parks in his book
he pays tribute the whole history of the
civil rights movement
may have been different
but
for claudette at the age of 16 she made
headlines again as one of four
plaintiffs in the lawsuit that would end
alabama's bus segregation
in the landmark browder versus gale
supreme court decision
when you won in court yes you could sit
in the front row if you want yes
and did you
yes
but the charge of assaulting police
officers remained fast forward to today
when judge calvin williams in montgomery
alabama read her appeal he expunged her
66 year old criminal record and i'm no
longer a juvenile delinquent at 82. she
was not present when the judge ruled she
didn't know his name she didn't even
know what he looked like we have a
surprise
it was a surprise we have a surprise for
you what is this advice
someone would like to meet you
what's up
hello miss calvin
judge calvin williams
church calvin williams oh my goodness
lord
[Laughter]
oh my goodness on behalf of myself
and all of the judges of montgomery
offer my apology
for an injustice
that was perpetrated upon you wow this
is a surprise
[Laughter]
so you didn't know that the judge who
did this was african-american no
and i'm so proud
the judge wasn't even born when miss
colvin refused to give up her seat on
that bus when she did this in 1955 there
were no african-american judges in
montgomery
she stood up for right
and now i'm the beneficiary and
byproduct of that and i could correct
the wrong
that was done to her it meant to that
amen to that can i squeeze your hand yes
ma'am please do
so great
oh
david she's giggling like a little girl
all morning when we said surprise you
won't want to miss something and i hope
it lives up to it but it did it did and
i love tissues here at the table yes i
love how she called on the ancestors
harriet and sojourner who had her hands
on had their hands on her shoulders and
said don't get up i'm glued to the seat
because of history
beautifully done she had been studying
black history in school and it became so
important to her that she just felt
moved that's right
before the movement itself with rosa
parks had taken off she was independent
and you may be wondering why why not
claudette colvin why rosa parks why is
that the one we hear about yes and
according to miss colvin she was 15 and
pregnant
and so she said the civil rights leaders
didn't want a young rebel rouser
pregnant girl to represent the movement
mrs parks was a well-respected secretary
of the naacp who according to miss
colvin
was lighter in color and they thought
that it would be more appealing to put
her forward as a face of the movie and
those were the times we were living
in her graciousness says but that's not
to take anything away from what miss
parker of course right
um
but and and why now you may be wondering
well like why why do now you're 82. she
said when i saw the george floyd
protests
it kind of reignited a spirit in her an
activist spirit and she said i just
wanted my kids and the great-grandbabies
to see that even at 82 in a wheelchair
yeah i still had a fight left you know
and we saw kids her age and younger out
there she was 15. david that's right 15
it's a reminder we are walking in her
footsteps yes we are thank you claudette
colvin great job what a lady the
surprise lives up to it well done david
thank you very much